[MUSIC PLAYING]
SHANE GLASS: Good afternoon,
and welcome the "Cloud OnAir,"
live webinars from Google Cloud.
We're hosting webinars
every Tuesday.
My name is Shane Glass.
With me today is Andrew Whitby.
And today, we'll be talking
about the Visualize 2030
Challenge.
You can ask questions at
any time on the platform.
And we have Googlers
standing by to answer them.
Let's get started.
So I will say with a note first,
this is a little different
than my last live experience,
which was a 2010 baseball
game I was broadcasting.
I imagine the story will
be a little different.
So we're talking about the
Visualize 2030 Challenge today.
It's a data-driven story to
talk about how at least two
of the UN's Sustainable
Development Goals
influence each other
and what actions
might be taken in order to
reach the goals set out in 2030.
Let's learn more
about the challenge.
We encourage you to
visit the link here
on the site on the page.
And I think it's really
important that we call out
here that this is a real
opportunity for students that
are eligible for the contest--
university students--
to have a great impact on
the improvement of the world
around them.
The Visualize 2030 Challenge
is done in collaboration
with the World Bank, the
United Nations Foundation,
and the Global Partnership
for Sustainable Development.
We're collaborating with
them, because it just gives us
such a broader reach.
And, Andrew, I think
we'd love to hear
your perspective on that.
ANDREW WHITBY: Yes,
that sounds like my cue.
So I'm a data scientist
in Development Data
Group at the World Bank.
And for people who don't
know the World Bank,
we're a multilateral institution
with about 189 member
countries, I think.
And we work in the
realm of financing
and technical assistance
for countries, mostly
low and middle-income
countries, to help them
in development
projects, so things
like improving a health
system, or building new roads,
or maybe expanding sanitation
and electricity networks, stuff
like that.
But we also work on
collecting and publishing data
about development.
And I guess that's my
role in the organization,
and that's why I'm here
talking to you today.
So if you skip on
to the next slide,
I can talk a little bit about
the United Nations' Sustainable
Development Goals, which is
the focus of the challenge.
The story of this is kind
of interesting to talk
about this week,
because at the moment,
not far from where we're
standing here in New York,
the United Nations General
Assembly is meeting.
And they did the same thing
as they do in every year.
They did the same thing
in 2015, as it turns out,
on this exact date.
They passed this
resolution committing
to these 17 goals for
sustainable development
to take place over the period
up to, in general, 2030
is the target date
for these goals.
And you can already
see from the screen,
it's quite a broad set of things
that they're working towards.
But I'll read a couple
of them in full,
because I think it gives you
some sense of the ambition.
You can't necessarily tell
from the little picture form.
So goal 1 is to end poverty
in all its forms everywhere.
Goal 4 is to ensure inclusive
and equitable quality education
and promote lifelong learning
opportunities for all.
Goal 5 is to achieve
gender equality
and empower all women and girls.
Goal 10 is to reduce inequality
within and among countries.
Goal 14 is to conserve
and sustainably use
the oceans, seas, and marine
resources for sustainable
development.
So it's not just about people.
It's about the earth
environment as well.
And goal 16 is to promote
peaceful and inclusive
societies, provide access
to justice for all,
and to build accountable
institutions at all levels.
So yeah, it's a very
broad spread of goals.
And there's kind of some
history to this that's worth
keeping in mind, which is it
was a previous set of goals--
the Millennium
Development Goals-- that
was agreed on about
2000 and then carried
through to the
2015 point in time.
And so this set
of goals is really
replacing a previous
set of targets--
many of which were achieved
and some which were not--
in that period.
But like I said, these
are mostly setting goals
to be achieved by 2030.
And the thing, I think,
when you listen to them
as I read them out and when
you look at them on the screen
here, they're kind of big,
lofty, general ideals.
SHANE GLASS: Huge ambitions.
ANDREW WHITBY: Right.
I mean, they're not things
that you can necessarily easily
measure.
They're a little bit abstract.
And so there's a
kind of framework
under these to make that a
bit more measurable, to make
this thing really work, which
is that under these 17 goals,
there are 169 targets.
I won't read all of them
out or even a selection.
But they're more detailed,
more specific things
that you can look at and
say, yes, that was achieved
or that wasn't, by the
time we reach 2030.
And then underneath those
targets, each of them
has usually between one
and three indicators.
And that's where the
rubber hits the road.
You get down to these concrete
outcomes that can be measured.
And I can give you
some real examples
of those that might make
it a little bit clearer.
So like I said,
the first goal is
to end poverty in all
its forms everywhere.
And that has a number of
targets associated with it.
The first of those targets
is called target 1.1, very
numerical order to these things.
And that is, by 2030, eradicate
extreme poverty for all people
everywhere, currently
measured as people
living below $1.25 a day.
And that $1.25 is an
international poverty line,
that is re-evaluated
from time to time.
It's actually moved since then.
But that target has an
indicator associated with it.
And so that's what you'll
find in the data set.
And that indicator
is the proportion
of the population below
the international poverty
line by sex, age,
employment status,
and geographic location--
that is, whether people
live in an urban or rural area.
And so that's the
structure of how
you get from these
lofty ambitious goals
down to something
that we can actually
take and visualize and talk
about in concrete terms.
So yeah, that's the first thing.
These things have
to be measurable.
And then the second thing
that you might have picked up
from what I was talking about
is that whereas the previous set
of goals we had, the Millennium
Development Goals, it
was very much about
country averages.
It was a very
broad-brush approach
to looking at this stuff.
One of the emphases
in the SDGs--
the Sustainable
Development Goals--
is to be able to
disaggregate that
and to look within countries.
So in that indicator for
poverty that I read out,
you could see that
it was broken down
by sex, and by age, and
by employment status,
and the urban-rural location.
So you're really looking
at sub-populations
within countries and making
sure, as the SDG mantra goes,
that nobody is left
behind, that everybody
is captured in these data sets.
So that's the brief
intro to the SDGs.
SHANE GLASS: And so
just to summarize that,
at the high level, you
have the end poverty.
And when you did down into
the indicator, that's truly
your measurable way
of saying, here's
how we're making progress.
Here's where we're
making progress.
ANDREW WHITBY: Exactly.
In principle, we should
be able to take a country
and take a point
in time and attach
a number to that indicator and
say, the poverty rate in Malawi
in 2018 is this number.
So that's the idea.
SHANE GLASS: OK,
that makes sense.
ANDREW WHITBY: So then the
next question, I guess,
for me is, why am I here?
Why am I not at my
desk at the World Bank?
Why am I at Google talking
about this contest?
And I think that comes
down to this slide, which
is that data has power.
And it hasn't always
been accessible.
So thinking about how it
hasn't been accessible--
and this is a mea culpa, in
a way, from the World Bank--
that up until fairly
recently, and certainly
in the pre-internet era, if you
wanted to get hold of our data,
such as it is, you would send
us a check for about $300.
And we would send you
back a physical disk.
And that works fine for the
libraries and universities
and stuff.
But it obviously meant that a
lot of people around the world
didn't have access to this
data and especially people
from low-income backgrounds.
For people who we're
most trying to help,
this data was
completely inaccessible.
So in about 2010,
the World Bank really
swung behind the
open data movement.
And so now, all
our data is online.
It's free as long as there's no
privacy restrictions stopping
us publishing it.
That's something that is
available to everybody.
And that's where this
contest comes around.
This is another way of
us promoting our data,
getting that out to people,
and getting people to use it.
And I think why
that's important,
I can give an example
of a World Bank project
that was based around data,
which is this thing called
Doing Business.
What they do is they go
from country to country,
and they just
collect information
about how easy it is operate
a business in that country.
So how much paperwork does
it take to start a company?
SHANE GLASS: How interesting.
ANDREW WHITBY: Or
how long does it
take to get an electricity
connection set up?
How easy is it to
resolve legal disputes?
Those sorts of things that are
day-to-day work for a business.
And this projects has been
going on for a number of years.
And all they really do
is publish this data.
They publish rankings
of countries and so on.
But the effect that
it has is quite large.
Because citizens, businesses,
journalists in countries
will look and say,
well, our country
is falling behind
these other neighboring
countries, who are
better on this measure
or this other measure.
And so that can promote a sort
of responsiveness of government
to try and fix some
of these problems.
It's not just about these
kind of business measures.
The same thing happens with
measures of life expectancy,
or more recently, in some
high-income countries,
maternal mortality has been
getting worse rather than
getting better.
There's been a lot of great
journalistic work done
taking this publicly-available
data and then writing about it.
Then citizens can
take that issue,
and try and do
something about it.
SHANE GLASS: In a
lot of ways, what I'm
hearing you say is that it's
a means of accountability
for whether its governments or
non-governmental organizations,
or whoever the
appropriate body is.
ANDREW WHITBY: Yeah, exactly.
And so that's part of it is
really bringing about change.
The other side to it
that I think is important
and we shouldn't forget
about is just the value
in individual
citizens of countries
understanding what other
people in the world's lives
are like, how they live.
I don't know if you're
familiar with Hans
Wesseling-- the late Hans
Wesseling, unfortunately.
He was a great data
visualization data
communicator.
If you haven't
seen his stuff, you
should get on YouTube after
this session and look him up.
But one of the points
he consistently made
was that even the
best-informed people, maybe
people like ourselves,
about some of the issues,
we still know very little
about other countries.
People will still
routinely misjudge
what the poverty rate
is in a certain country
or the unemployment rate in
other places, stuff like that.
So it's valuable just to have
access to this data and people
be able to see it and
understand the world better.
SHANE GLASS: You hit on a key
point there of accessibility.
And that's where I come in.
ANDREW WHITBY: That's right.
SHANE GLASS: As our
viewers saw earlier,
I manage the Google Cloud
Public Dataset Program.
Public data sets and
open data, in general,
is something that's always
been kind of near and dear
to my heart.
As I worked on my
master's, I would
spend 10, 12 hours a week
searching for data sets,
looking for data sets,
trying to find something,
anything I could
use to work with.
And that's kind of how I
became passionate about this.
But what I found over
time is a few things
with public data sets.
One is that we'll
never truly understand.
We could be the leading subject
matter experts in the data.
We'll never truly imagine all
the possible legitimate use
cases of this data.
So by making it
open and accessible,
you open it up to
a whole new world
of innovation and new
ideas that you might not
have had in the past.
But the other thing is-- and
you talked about this earlier--
there is legitimate
costs associated
with creating disks
and shipping disks,
but if we can host it
out, in this case, on GCP,
and make it easier
for people to get to,
we can become a little smarter.
We can become a little better.
And we can become a little bit
more prepared for the world
around us.
I think that's where
we've collaborated
together is hosting
this data in BigQuery
and just making it so much
easier for people to get to
and to use.
ANDREW WHITBY: Yeah, absolutely.
We're happy to see our data
spread as far and as wide
as it can be.
SHANE GLASS: Absolutely.
And that's our goal too.
ANDREW WHITBY: Right.
SHANE GLASS: So I mentioned the
Cloud Public Dataset Program.
Just to give you a
little overview on that,
we work with public data
providers, like the World Bank,
like the National Oceanic and
Atmospheric Administration--
NOAA-- among others to
host valuable data sets
or copies of their
valuable data sets in GCP,
so that users can find them,
discover them, and utilize them
much more quickly.
And what we found
is that removes
a level of friction or a barrier
to entry that keeps people
from utilizing data and
from doing great things
in the first place.
I talked a little bit
earlier about BigQuery.
There are more than 100 data
sets available in BigQuery.
Just passed 100 data
sets and just passed
100 petabytes of data scanned in
the three years of the program.
So we're really
excited about that.
But it's not all
structured data.
We do about seven petabytes of
data in Google Cloud Storage.
Most of that is
satellite imagery,
so things like the USGS Landsat
from meteorological satellites
as well.
So certainly a lot of
things out there that can
unlock the imagination
in some ways
and can help, whether
it's a university student,
like those eligible
for this contest,
or if it's a startup that
wants to experiment on this,
but needs access to
the data to do so.
They can do so, I
think, much faster.
Of course, all of
our data can be
visualized in Data
Studio, which is what
we're going to focus on today.
For those of you
that aren't familiar,
Data Studio is our free
Visual Analytics product.
They can connect
the data directly
from BigQuery, from
the user interface,
or from other directions,
whether it's the BigQuery data
connector in Data Studio or
if it's through Google Sheets.
So certainly a lot of
options there as well.
And don't worry, we are going
to play with Data Studio today.
Just a real quick
overview-- where can we
find these data sets?
Where can we learn a
little bit more about them?
I encourage our
users and our viewers
to go onto GCP
Marketplace, where
you can see on the
left-hand side,
there's a list of
data sets there.
And that'll give you a
high-level overview of the data
sets, some information
about the source, something
like where it came from and
who's the provider of it,
as well as some sample queries
and some sample demonstrations
to help you get started
as quickly as possible.
OK, so this is the fun part.
Andrew, can you tell us a
little bit about the World Data
Indicators?
ANDREW WHITBY: Yeah, the
World Development Indicators.
I can.
It's not unstructured data.
It's not huge.
It's not petabytes like the
satellite data might be.
In storage size terms, it's a
fairly small, structured data
set.
But in terms of
development indicators,
it's relatively large.
It's produced by the group that
I'm working with at the Bank.
It's been going for maybe
40 years now, I think.
And it's structured as a cube.
So you have about 1,500
development indicators
on different topics from health,
and education, and poverty,
and government spending, and
all kinds of things like that
by about 200 countries--
plus or minus--
and by about up to 60 years.
So the earliest date we have,
generally, is about 1960
that the collection begins.
And some data sets start
later that that, because it
wasn't collected back then.
I should say, also, that this
is available in lots of ways,
not just through your platform.
SHANE GLASS: Absolutely.
ANDREW WHITBY: So people
can go to our website,
and you can access it directly.
You can download a
bulk csv download
if you just want the whole thing
in one go on your computer.
You can access an
API that we have
to be able to use it
programmatically or through R
or Python, tools like that.
And so you might
be wondering, what
is the connection
between this data set
and the Sustainable
Development Goals
that I talked about earlier?
And if you were listening
really carefully,
you might have heard
me say, well, there
are 1,500 indicators in this.
And the SDGs had
about 300 indicators
underneath those goals.
So one thing, obviously, is this
is a much more comprehensive
data set.
And that's probably because
it's been around for a while,
so it's collected a lot of
different indicators over time.
But also, it's supposed
to be more comprehensive.
Whereas, the SDG's,
everything is supposed
to relate to a target and
this kind of structured way
of thinking about
data, WDI is much more
a way of just
understanding the world
and understanding how
other countries look
at development measures.
So it gives you an
example of things
that you might find in
here that don't directly
connect to the SDGs, but
might still be interesting.
You'll find something like
life expectancy in here.
And there's no SDG target
on life expectancy.
But what there is in
SDG goals is the target,
for instance 3.3,
which is on reducing
the burden of HIV/AIDS.
And so if you're trying
to think about that,
it might be useful to
actually understand
the context of life expectancy
in different countries
to make sense of that.
I think we may see an
example of that later on.
SHANE GLASS: Spoiler
alert-- we will.
ANDREW WHITBY: Spoiler alert.
But another example
would be population.
So there's no population
targets for either the world
or for countries in the
Sustainable Development Goals.
But there is, for
instance, a target
around improving housing
and upgrading slums.
But obviously, that's intimately
related to population.
So it's useful to have
these other indicators
alongside the SDG
indicators to be
able to make sense of the
world and tell a better story,
I think.
SHANE GLASS: And having
that historical context
helps you understand, OK, we
had the Millennium Development
Goals.
And now, we have the
Sustainable Development Goals.
It helps you understand how
did we get where we are today,
and what's been done in the
past that maybe has or has not
worked.
It helps you better
understand how to tell a story
and what's truly
happening in the world.
ANDREW WHITBY: Yeah, exactly.
The data landscape
reflects that, right?
When I say this
started 40 years ago,
it didn't start with 1,500
indicators 40 years ago.
It started with two, probably,
and it's grown since.
The last thing I
should say about WDI
is, I'm standing here
talking about it.
But it's not just the
World Bank's work.
We collect data from a lot
of partners from UN agencies,
from country governments,
from private companies.
And they really deserve the
credit for collecting the data.
We just collate it and make
it more easily available.
SHANE GLASS: So it's
truly is an effort, then,
from the global community
to come together.
ANDREW WHITBY: It is, yeah.
And now, you're hosting
on your platform
is an extension of that to
make it even more available.
SHANE GLASS: Excellent.
All right, well, let's dig into
the data here a little bit.
And let's dig into some
of the visualizations.
So we'll start here.
This is a basic visualization I
put together that demonstrates,
I believe, it's Sustainable
Development Goal 8, Indicator
8.1.1, which looks
at the percentage
of the population in a given
country that have access
to electricity.
And so you'll see the heat
map up here on the top.
The color by countries, I
sometimes jokingly refer to it,
kind of identifies where the
red is a larger percentage
of the population has access
to electricity-- the deep red--
whereas, that blue,
it really stands out,
in sub-Saharan
Africa especially,
has a significantly lower
percentage of the population
with access to electricity.
And you can see called out there
at the bottom, the 15 or 20
countries with the
lowest percentage
of the total population.
And I think this is a
great example of what
you talked about earlier about
how the different indicators
break down.
Because this is 8.1.1.
This looks at the
total population.
But then 8.1.2 looks
at rural populations,
and 8.1.3 looks at the
urban population with access
to electricity.
So I think this is a
great example and a very
high-level overview of what's
possible with Data Studio.
And so let's dig into--
you have some examples.
And I have some examples.
ANDREW WHITBY: Yeah, exactly.
SHANE GLASS: And we'll
show them side by side?
ANDREW WHITBY: Yeah, I think so.
Yeah, I think that'll work.
This is an example
of a visualization
that we made
earlier in the year.
And it comes from a
print publication,
the "Atlas of the Sustainable
Development Goals."
So it was made as a book.
You can find a PDF.
And there's also
an online version
that you should be able
to find pretty easily.
But the point of
that publication
is really trying to
tell these data stories
that were looking
at in this contest,
in our own particular way.
So this one is you're looking
at, here, a map of the world,
obviously, and it's a choropleth
map, the kind of map where
each country's colored a
different intensity to show
a number for the country.
And what it's showing
is this measure
of air pollution called PM 2.5.
And PM 2.5 relates
to target, I think,
11.6, which is talking about
the environmental quality
in cities.
And PM 2.5 is
important, because it's
a very small size of particle.
It's smaller than one-thirtieth
the size of a human hair.
And it's the kind of
thing that you can inhale,
and it will lodge
deeply in your lungs.
And then it can cause disease.
High levels of PM 2.5 are bad.
And there's a World Health
Organization recommendation
for the maximum exposure
you should face.
So one of the things, I
think, that the question that
is raised for me that I
think is worth thinking about
is, you have to be
careful around some
of these indicators.
So with the WDI data
sets, as you've loaded up,
people can find
the metadata there.
And that will tell you something
about how it was created.
So in this case,
this is actually
measuring that PM 2.5
measure across a country,
but then population
weighting it.
So it kind of reflects
the average exposure
that a person in that
country might have.
And that's actually slightly
different to what the SDG
target is looking at, which is
people in cities, particularly
urban people, across the entire
country or across the world.
And maybe only half of
people live in cities.
So in a sense, this is an
interesting visualization.
But it's important to
bear those differences
from the SDG target in mind.
But I think you have a version
of this as well, right?
SHANE GLASS: Yeah.
Before we step on to
that-- so PM 2.5 typically
comes from burning things,
whether it's fuel, whether it's
for cooking, for electricity.
But I think some of the
areas highlighted here
could also be seen as coming
from natural sources as well.
ANDREW WHITBY:
Yeah, that's right.
I'm not an expert in almost
any of these specific targets.
SHANE GLASS: Nor am I.
ANDREW WHITBY: But we produced
this book to try and look
at the different areas.
And so one of the
interesting things
is to dig into that metadata
and say, well, actually,
what is this measuring?
And it turns out that
PM 2.5 also measures
a lot of wind-blown sand.
So if you have a city in
the middle of a desert,
you may have high
levels of PM 2.5.
And it's not air
pollution like we
would think of factories, and
cars, and stuff like that.
It's natural pollution.
And yet, it's still
measured by this.
So that's another reason
that people really
should look at the metadata
of things they're analyzing.
SHANE GLASS: Yeah, so we'll
flip over to the Data Studio
version of this.
I've very creatively
copy and pasted
a lot of the text that
was on the World Bank's
version of this.
But I think one thing that's
also really interesting
is you kind of tend
to see that cluster.
These kind of countries that
see the biggest impact from this
tend to be clustered together.
And that's important,
because air pollution
doesn't obey the laws
of political boundaries.
And so it's important,
as we mentioned earlier,
for this global effort, this
global community to come
together to work on this.
We talked about the
text that's on here.
We kind of went back
and forth earlier.
You mentioned the World Bank had
given a lot of thought to this.
And I actually think it's really
one of most valuable things
that the World Bank
brings to the table here.
It's not just the
creation and the data--
that's obviously valuable--
but that expertise and that
understanding of data as well.
ANDREW WHITBY: Interestingly,
the publication
that I've opened this
came from is entirely
data story [INAUDIBLE].
It's entirely visualizations.
There's no paragraph
of the text.
And that was something that
was hard for us to adjust to.
Because we're
like, well, we need
to include these caveats
and these explanations
that we would normally
spend a page writing about.
But somehow, we need to fit
these into two sentences that
fit somewhere on a chart.
So that was a kind of
interesting experience for us.
I think it becomes a really
powerful way of, then, simply,
but at the same time,
richly explaining the story.
SHANE GLASS: OK, so I
can sit here and explain
exactly what you just
explained on the last one.
But I think we'd all rather dig
into the how it's made on this.
ANDREW WHITBY: Yeah,
I'm curious to see.
SHANE GLASS: OK,
let's take a look.
So what we're looking at here
now is the dashboard view.
So you can share this
with anybody, anyone.
As long as you set the
share settings properly,
you can view this from your web
browser using the Share button
I've got highlighted
here with the mouse.
But I think the more fun part
is to go into the edit mode.
So we've got this pulled up.
And this gives you
a really nice look
at what you'll see when
you first enter Data Studio
and when you first
start working with data.
So I'll call this out
just ahead of time here.
A lot of this text
is manually input.
I may or may not have run out
of time to do it another way.
So you'll notice that it
might not scale probably
the way that would be ideal.
But let's take a look
at some of the features
of Data Studio
that have helped us
create this visualization here.
So I'll select this geographic
map that we've created here.
And you'll see it pops up a
list of your available fields
here on the right side and
a list of the dimensions
and the metrics
you're measuring here.
So let's dig into how
we can add data sources
and then how we
can begin to work
with them for the analysis.
So what you'll see
here is the data source
is already loaded up.
If I click, Add
a Data Source, it
takes me out to the
whole list of connectors.
There's 20-some-odd
Google connectors.
There's more partner
connectors down here.
For the purposes
of this contest,
you want to use the data sets
that are available through
the website we
mentioned earlier,
the
cloud.google.com/visualize2030.
So we'll skip out
of this for now.
I think this is probably
less exciting for the viewers
than playing around
with the data.
But if we go into our
Resource tab again,
now, we can look at
blending data sets.
So this allows us to bring
together both the World Bank's
data sets and the UN data sets.
We have just the UN
data sets loaded up
in this particular
visualization.
But if I wanted to come in
here and blend this data,
it's kind of a visualization
of a join in SQL.
I would add another data source.
And I would say,
let's take something
I was working with earlier.
So the World Bank,
for instance, I
hear those guys do good stuff.
So we'll add that to my report.
And then you can see it gives
me a list of the fields here.
And I can give a common
join field between the two.
In this case, I would probably
use countries, country name,
and geo area name.
But we'll set this
aside for now as
well, so we can dig into
some of the other features.
And, yes, I'm very sure I
want to discard these changes.
OK, so the one last thing
we want to dig into,
and you can see down here,
it's on a scale of 1 to 4.
which is very different
than what the World Bank's
visualization was.
What I've done
there is I've just
created a custom
bin for our users
to be able to go in
and say, once I've
created a copy of this data
set that we've made available--
that's important, because it
allows users to edit the data,
to create their own fields,
to create calculated fields.
And it allows them to
create the custom bins
like these, using match
statements or case statements,
so that our users can more
clearly visualize things.
It can get a little
cluttered when
you have a map like this that
has 100 different colors on it.
So I think the World Bank
took a great approach
to that of really narrowing
that down to the four key areas
to create these
areas that stand out.
Andrew, if I were
to ask you, what
do you see that stands
out on this map?
ANDREW WHITBY:
Yeah, like you say,
the clustering of
dark areas, I think,
jumps out most immediately.
SHANE GLASS: So we were trading
favorite data visualization
professors earlier and
mine being Stephen Few, who
talks about the hierarchy
of visual information,
how the human brain
interprets that--
color being at or near the top.
Size, I think, is
probably ahead of that.
But this is very
deep red stands out
against the contrast of
that white background.
And so we can see what,
for lack of a better term,
the problem areas are, the
areas we want to focus on.
And that allows you to
call out these areas,
whether it's in Africa,
it's in Southeast Asia.
And I think that
really clearly helps
you identify the
beginning of a trend,
the beginning of a story.
So we've dug through some of
these features in Data Studio.
One thing that I've really
enjoyed about Data Studio
is the ability to drill
down at the continent level.
So if we take this
and we say, gosh,
what's happening in Africa
is really standing out to me,
I can drill down to Africa.
So what I really
like is you still
have the context of the
rest of the globe around it.
But it allows you to get
a closer look at what
each of these countries see.
And so we'll go back to
our view here for a moment.
And now, you can go over
and highlight and say,
well, what's the actual value
in each of these countries?
Here, because they're binned,
it's probably less exciting.
We'll take a look at a
more exciting one later.
But it allows you to
truly get an understanding
of what's happening in
that country at a very
granular level.
ANDREW WHITBY: Yeah,
interestingly, the reason
we binned it is
because one of outputs
was a print publication.
And it's very hard to tell
12 shades of red, at least
at the print quality
we can afford.
But on screen, I imagine,
you could probably
get away not binning
it and just having
the full range of values.
And then you'll be able to
see that when you [INAUDIBLE]..
SHANE GLASS: And that talks
to the first visualization
we saw, the access to
electricity as well.
ANDREW WHITBY: Exactly.
SHANE GLASS: One of
the fun things here
as well, we put in
a filter for year.
And so this allows the viewer to
go down and say, you know what?
Hey, let's look at just
2014, for instance.
So it allows you to come
down here and select 2014.
I've got this set
to single select.
Looks like we might not
have data for that year.
So I've got it set
to single select,
so it will only show
me a single year.
But if I had set it to multiple
years, I could show an average,
or I could show the sum of
those value over time as well.
So I think that's another really
great demonstration of what
are we truly seeing here,
and what is our story here.
One visualization
does not a story make.
But it can tell you the
beginning of a story.
And you can string
these together
to tell the true
story of whether it's
looking at the historical
context of using the data going
back 40, 50 years,
or whether it's
what the situation on
the ground is today.
So let's look at
another one then.
ANDREW WHITBY: Yeah, so this
is another visualization
taken from our "Atlas of
Sustainable Development Goals."
And this one's kind
of interesting,
because it's an unusual
take on a familiar issue.
So this is relating to
target 3.3, which includes
ending the AIDS epidemic.
But rather than taking
an indicator on HIV/AIDS
particularly, like the
prevalence rate, for instance,
what we're looking at
here is life expectancy.
So just to sort of
quickly understand
what you're looking
at, each line
represents the history
of life expectancy
in a particular country.
And we've used color to put
all the countries on there
in a way that, hopefully,
isn't too overwhelming.
But what's the first
thing that jumps out
at you from looking at that?
SHANE GLASS: So
I'm kind of looking
at the holistic pattern,
everything moving up
and to the right, which
is good news, right?
ANDREW WHITBY: Yeah, exactly.
That's exactly right.
One of the things we
want people to see
is that, well, you can
look on the left-hand end,
and the lowest life expectancy
that a country had in 1960
was 28, which is a pretty
young age for life expectancy.
By 2016, that's now up to 51,
the lowest country in a data
set.
So that's a general
improvement across time.
But I said that this was a data
visualization about HIV/AIDS.
And so now we can
dig in and say, well,
why is that what we're showing?
And so what we've
done here-- we've
highlighted in
yellow the countries
in sub-Saharan Africa.
That's the World Bank region
that was most affected by,
or has been most
affected by AIDS.
But then on top of
that, we've also
highlighted in a slightly
thicker line there,
bolded countries, countries
that had the highest prevalence
of HIV/AIDS over that period.
I think there's 10 countries
highlighted there maybe.
And what you see from that
is that those countries,
the life expectancy
was increasing in line
with all the other countries.
But then sometime
around the mid-90s
through to the
mid-2000s, they've
actually been decreasing.
And I find that
fascinating, because it's
a reflection of this
awful epidemic in terms
of dry, demographic data
that you might not otherwise
look at that way.
On the plus side, you
can see that from about
the mid-2000s onwards,
these life expectancy lines
start to tick up again
as treatment gets better,
as prevention gets better,
as awareness increases.
SHANE GLASS: Yeah,
it looks like they
were able to recover
most of that loss
that they saw in the
late '90s, early-2000s.
ANDREW WHITBY: Yeah, maybe.
SHANE GLASS: Yeah, so
I think we'll flip over
to Data Studio version.
We talked earlier about digging
in at a very granular level
to this data.
And you can see, I've chosen
to go with obscurity by color
to kind of move the context
behind it by using size.
We talked about
earlier about size
being such a big
hierarchical importance
for how your brain interprets
these visualizations.
And I've chosen to call out
two countries in particular--
one being Rwanda, and
the other being Zambia--
by using the size, by increasing
the thickness of these lines.
And you can see the
exact same pattern here.
Now, what's really
interesting about this
is you can mouse over this.
And you can see, hey,
here is exactly what
the data was at a given point.
So if I come back
to, for instance,
1997, like we called out, OK,
I can see the Zambian life
expectancy of 43 years.
But if I come out here to 2016
or 2015, it's back up to 61--
closer to or even above
where it was in 1977 at 51.
And so I think this
is another great way
that some of the
features in Data Studio
can help the students
out there participating
in this challenge
really understand
what's happening here and really
show what's happening here.
ANDREW WHITBY: Yeah.
We've explored lots of
different interactive tools.
And we haven't really done
an awful lot of that stuff.
But it's a limitation
of what we've
done in terms of
static visualizations
that you can't see
individual data points.
You get general trend.
SHANE GLASS: Right, exactly.
And that's one thing I like
about the interactivity
of this.
It's that ability to really,
again, uncover that story
that you're going to tell.
Again, we talked
about adding context
with text on here earlier.
I think the World Bank has
done a great job of this,
of adding this context in here.
But our users aren't going
to have this context when
they begin to visualize.
And so I like that there's
the ability to call this out
and to very clearly say, hey,
we can discover our own context
in here.
ANDREW WHITBY: Yeah, I
think I was telling you
before that I
suspect when we first
produced our version
of this chart,
we just graphed the
life expectancies.
And we actually noticed
the patterns of reductions.
And you look at that, and
you say, well, some countries
are doing something different
from the general increase
everyone else is doing.
You probe into it, and
you can pretty quickly
come up with the explanation.
That's the kind
of roundabout way
by which we have
gotten to it, I think.
SHANE GLASS: As a data
analyst, I look at that,
and I say, what's interesting
to me is what's different.
That's really what calls out
to me is the general pattern
move up and to the
right is great news,
and is of importance,
and should be examined.
But really digging
into telling that story
is, what's different?
And what stands out?
And what's the cause of that?
That's one thing that's
really exciting for me.
We talked a lot about using
Data Studio last time.
One thing I forgot to
call out is this ability
to set the size of the
dashboard up front.
And you can set multiple pages.
I only have one per
visualization here.
So don't feel the need to create
a massive, oversized single
page.
But one thing I really
like in visualization
is that ability to use the
limitations of your screen size
to your advantage of creating
something that the user has
to scroll down to discover.
I think it helps the storyteller
communicate the message,
but a controlled manner,
step users through in a way
that they want to see it.
I currently have
it set to what I
think would be most convenient
for our users on the webinar
today.
But maybe set the width a
little more narrow and setting
the heights at 10,000 pixels.
And really let the
viewer scroll through
and go through that
discovery journey with you.
We'll jump back to
the slides here.
I think what we're
seeing here, Andrew,
is a really great demonstration
of what's possible
and how to get started
here in Data Studio,
and how you can take
the WDI data set
and really just dig into it,
and explore, and uncover stuff
that maybe no one's
ever seen before.
And that, to me,
is really exciting,
especially for the
students that are
interested in having
an impact and improving
the world around them.
ANDREW WHITBY: Right.
We've barely scraped the surface
of the data that's in there.
I think you have some other
data sets as well there
that people can look at and
combine to do visualizations.
So hopefully, people find
some interesting things.
SHANE GLASS: I think
they will, absolutely.
So we talked a lot about
telling the story today.
I think that narrative
came up a lot.
I think what we want
students to do here
is tell your friends, folks.
If you are a student, dig in.
Have fun visualizing
the data set.
Use the hashtag #Visualize2030.
Check out the website
that's here as well.
And make a difference.
Who knows?
Maybe you'll even win $10,000.
I don't know anyone that
wouldn't want to win $10,000.
If you're not a student,
tell your friends who are.
If you're not a
university student,
tell your friends who you are.
Tell your family that are.
And let them know
about this opportunity
that we have out
there available.
Again, the deadline for
this is November 16.
So I think that's coming up a
lot faster than I expected it
to, given that
September's almost over.
It feels like
September just started.
So certainly, get out
and get cracking on this.
And we're looking
forward to seeing
what comes through on this.
ANDREW WHITBY: Definitely.
SHANE GLASS: All right, well,
that's it for us, folks.
We're going to step away
for just a moment here.
But stay tuned for a
live Q&A. Andrew and I,
we're back in less
than a minute.
OK, welcome back, everyone.
I'm still here with Andrew.
And we've got some audience
questions coming in.
So let's dive right into these.
Andrew, I think this first one
is probably for both of us.
But how can data be made
more accessible to people
around the world?
ANDREW WHITBY: Yeah, I think
there's a few different aspects
to that.
The internet has
made this just vastly
different than it was before.
That's the big step change.
But there are other
things we think about,
too, like, licensing
issues can be very
restrictive in preventing people
from getting access to data
they otherwise might.
So we're always working
to try and negotiate
better licenses with
people we get data from,
so we can share it.
And then the other thing that I
think is worth bearing in mind,
too, is the number
of people, especially
in low-income countries, who
are maybe accessing the internet
from mobile devices.
And so we're always
conscious of how long does
it take to load the World Bank's
web page on a mobile device
on the kind of
connection you might
have in a developing country.
And it's not always good.
SHANE GLASS: It's
great if you produce
the best website in the world.
But if no one can load it,
it doesn't really help.
ANDREW WHITBY: Exactly.
Yeah, yeah.
SHANE GLASS: And you
touched on licensing.
For me, that's probably
the big one as well.
One thing I see a
lot of is data sets
that are not licensed at all.
There's no license
attached to them.
And that can almost be worse
sometimes than a restriction
license, because it
will scare users off.
When users come in
and say, I don't
know if I'm going to get in
trouble for using this data
set, I'll play it safe.
I just won't use it.
Looking at some of the
open-source licenses that
are out there, whether it's
Apache, Creative Commons, MIT,
whatever one you want
to use, attaching
that open-source license to
your data set up front, I think,
can really help reduce that.
ANDREW WHITBY: We're as guilty
of that as the next person.
We used to not do
that really well.
We're doing it a
lot better from now.
You can usually find
World Bank data sets
and the license
attached to them.
SHANE GLASS: I mean, obviously,
the important part is
make the data available, right?
But the licensing is
kind of that next step.
ANDREW WHITBY: Yeah, especially
if you want data journalists
to use it in a publication.
And now, they're going to care
about that a little bit more
than maybe a student would.
SHANE GLASS: Sure, absolutely.
So this next one is, how can
we improve data collection
to ensure representation
and accuracy, especially
in developing countries?
ANDREW WHITBY: Yeah, that's a
huge, difficult issue, I think.
It depends a lot on the type
of data you're talking about.
We talked a little bit
about poverty data.
A lot of that
information comes from,
like large-scale
survey operations
that are pretty
expensive to run,
that the World Bank
and our partners
put a lot of money
and effort into doing.
And those, you
have the advantage
that you're doing
a formal survey,
so you can actually make
sure that it's representative
of people in the country.
But not all data is like that.
A lot of data that we use
today is secondary data
that you have as a side
effect of other things.
And so that can be much
more difficult to make sure
that they're representative.
You have these two
conflicting movements.
On the one hand, wanting to make
sure that nobody's left behind,
and that data is representative.
And on the other hand, you
have a lot of big data,
so people get really excited
about, like, what can we see
from people's internet usage?
There's been a lot of work in
development on cell phone data,
monitoring what kind of patterns
you can see in that data.
Academically, it's
really interesting.
But it has a downside.
You're only
collecting information
on people who have a cell
phone which in some countries,
is a minority of people.
SHANE GLASS: Absolutely.
ANDREW WHITBY: So there's
not a simple, single answer
to that question, I don't think.
It depends a lot on
where it is coming from
and what the topic is.
SHANE GLASS: So
real quick, what are
your thoughts on whether
it's representative
sampling or subsampling
populations to keep costs down
for those surveys you
mentioned, but still
getting a potentially
representative sample
of the population?
ANDREW WHITBY: Yeah.
It's going to be
interesting, actually.
We were talking before
and I was reading out
the poverty indicator.
And it says, proportion
of population
under international poverty line
by sex, age, employment status,
and geographic location.
We don't have that now.
You can go to the
World Bank website.
And you'll find poverty
as a national average,
for some large countries,
that we do that kind of thing.
The countries are cleverly
structuring their surveys
to get a urban/rural breakdown.
But I don't know
anywhere really where
you can get great data
on that broken down
by all of those things.
It's going to take, I
think, probably resources
for a start, more
investment, and maybe
some clever techniques
to get that done.
SHANE GLASS: And there's a
privacy issue there, too,
of saying, if there's only--
ANDREW WHITBY:
There is, there is.
SHANE GLASS: --people
in a rural area
that are males and not working,
that's another issue too.
ANDREW WHITBY: Yeah.
I think the SDGs aren't
going to hit that,
because they're not
disaggregating so much to get
down to cells of 10 people.
Most cases, we're
probably still talking
about hundreds of thousands
of people or tens of thousands
of people, the kinds
of disaggregates
that we'll be using
for this purpose.
But yeah, that definitely
becomes a problem
the more fine-grain you get.
SHANE GLASS: Absolutely.
So the third one here,
from your perspectives--
and I think this is
probably your perspective--
how do you measure success
in data collection?
What's a win for you guys?
Are there any areas that
you prioritize over others?
ANDREW WHITBY: Yes, the
second is easier for me
to speak to than the
first part in a way.
So from the World
Bank's perspective,
we sort of have a
special responsibility
for goals 1 and 10, the poverty
goal and the inequality goal.
The World Bank's role, at
least in recent history,
has been to work on
poverty particularly.
And inequality comes
along with that.
So particularly collecting
data on those things
has always been a
priority within the Bank.
Although, as I said, we're
involved in other areas
as well.
How do you measure success
in your data collection
and measurement?
Getting good quality data,
getting the cleanest data you
can get, I think, is important.
It's kind of interesting.
In my position and working
on this data set, the World
Development Indicators, I'm
not at the collection stage.
We're generally taking
this data from other people
who have already collected it.
And one thing-- you
can't tend to fix error
in data once they've
reached that point.
So collecting data, at
the point of collection,
making sure things are
as clean as possible
is, I think, one measure of
successful data collection.
And there's a lot
of technologies
that help with that right now.
People are working
on the tablets,
and doing interviews,
and collecting
GPS locations live,
and stuff like that.
Whereas, in the past, that
could have been a lot more error
prone when you're working
with pencil and paper.
SHANE GLASS: Yeah, and
especially as 5G starts to roll
out internationally--
obviously, we're
at the very early edge
of that-- but having
that improved bandwidth on
a mobile capacity, I think,
will help as well.
ANDREW WHITBY: I suspect a
lot of the places they're
collecting the poverty data,
they're lucky if they have 3G.
SHANE GLASS: Yeah, absolutely.
Again, we talked
about that level
of investment and
resourcing, it's
necessary to make a success.
ANDREW WHITBY: For sure.
SHANE GLASS: So we'll give
you a chance to breathe.
I'll take the first half
of this next question.
ANDREW WHITBY: Go for it.
Tell me.
SHANE GLASS: But I'd
love to hear you jump in.
What makes a good data story?
And what difference is there
between a data visualization
and an infographic?
To me, what makes a good
story is that ability
to walk the user through
the journey of discovery,
of saying, at this high
level, whether it's globally,
whether it's regionally, whether
it's at a continental level,
saying, OK, here's what
the situation looks like.
But let's dig in, and
let's learn either
why or how this
got to be and walk
the user through that journey.
And I really like that
process of people discovering
throughout the process-- not
giving all the information up
front, but using those
visualizations to help them
understand not only
what's happening,
but even why or
how it's happening.
In terms of the difference
between a data visualization
and an infographic-- we
were debating this earlier--
to me, a data
visualization is a lot
like what we looked at earlier,
where it's truly designed
to communicate the
data behind it,
whereas an infographic
is a little more designed
to tell a narrative
or a story in there--
tends to use less
data-y elements.
ANDREW WHITBY: Yeah,
more design elements
SHANE GLASS: More
pictorial elements.
ANDREW WHITBY: Yeah, exactly.
It's interesting, too,
when I think about what
makes a good data story.
It depends so much
on the medium.
And sometimes, you can choose
the medium you're working in.
But sometimes, you can't.
So the "Atlas" that
I was showing--
the visualizations from before--
that was kind of like a
traditional publication.
It was a print publication--
I wish I had a copy I could
plug right now to show you--
but also as a PDF.
It was online as an
afterthought to that.
And you end up with a
really different way
of telling the story
than if you start
from an interactive mindset.
Some of the stuff you're
seeing out of newsrooms
now on interactives,
they're just
really mind-blowing and amazing
because they're starting
to put it in perspective now.
They know that they
have a certain capacity
and a certain attention span
from users and stuff like that.
SHANE GLASS: Right.
And we talked earlier about
some of our favorite professors
for data visualization, whether
it's Stephen Few or Edward
Tufte or whomever.
I encourage our viewers
to go out and really
dig into that as well.
ANDREW WHITBY: Yeah, definitely,
and data journalists as well.
The stuff "'The New York
Times" newsroom does is pretty
amazing.
SHANE GLASS: Pretty
impressive, yeah.
So how can data
analytics be applied
to social and
environmental issues?
I'll give an example.
Before I came over to Google,
I was working with NOAA
to make their data,
very similar to this,
more publicly
accessible and usable.
And what we found is they had
produced some weather radar
data as part of their mission.
And they had made the
data available publicly.
It's available on GCP as
well as other sources.
And the strangest thing came in.
A group of ornithologists--
scientists studying
birds-- came in and said,
I can use that data to study
bird migration patterns.
And what's mind-blowing is
that to a meteorologist, that's
the noise in your signal.
But what's the noise
to the meterologist,
for the ornithologist
is the signal.
And the weather is the noise.
So, again, we talked about
applying data analytics
to social and
environmental issues.
I think the first step is making
that data available for people
to use, licensing it
properly, and then using
that to help gain that
understanding of the
how and why and what's
happening behind it,
and using that to communicate.
And I love the idea of a
data-driven application
of resources.
We talk about this a lot-- that
resourcing is not infinite.
And so using data to make an
informed decision about that,
I think, is really
critical as well.
ANDREW WHITBY: Yeah, definitely.
I think you've ticked off
some of the main things there.
SHANE GLASS: So
the last one here--
and I'm really glad
this question came in--
I forgot to mention it, but--
many fields in the data
sets use abbreviations
to store information.
Where can I find information
regarding those fields along
with the meaning of the
abbreviated data inside them?
ANDREW WHITBY: Yeah, so
that's a great question,
which I will take since
it's our data that we're
talking about today.
Just to explain why
we do that, if you
start to work with
country data at any scale,
you very quickly realize
that most countries
have many different names.
So you might have the
United States of America.
You might have
the United States.
You might have USA.
You might have America.
All of those things
in different data sets
might refer to the same country.
So a lot of the times, we'll try
to use standardized conventions
where we can.
So for instance, we include the
ISO three-letter country codes
for countries as well as
the name, the World Bank's
understanding of the official
name alongside there.
When I'm doing internal
manipulation of data,
and joining things,
and filtering things,
I try to use those codes
rather than the country names,
because I don't
like the dependency.
Countries change names as well.
That's something you
wouldn't imagine.
But you work in this
area, and suddenly, you
realize, every few years,
a country will actually
change its official name.
SHANE GLASS: Yeah, if you
tried a join on Zaire today,
you'd have some trouble.
ANDREW WHITBY: Right, exactly.
And those problems are
still filtering through data
sets you find today.
So that's the reason they
exist in the first place.
To find out what they refer
to, directly, I think,
as you've learned
about on your platform,
there's multiple tables.
There'll be a table
for, say, countries
where you'll see the
connection between countries
to some of the metadata
of the country.
The same from series,
you'll get more information
about the series itself
from a series table.
So you can find that stuff.
And, I guess, you can access
that through the platform
as well.
But if you go to our website
for World Development Indicators
on the World Bank website,
you can fairly easily
dig into that stuff.
It's not always as
obvious as it should be.
Some of those you may
have to dig down a bit.
And as a last, final result,
we also have a data help desk
email address, which I wish I
knew right now, but I don't.
But if you Google World
Bank data help desk,
I'm sure you'll
find the page that
gives you the email address.
And they're pretty good at
answering those queries.
So if you find something you
just can't make sense of--
SHANE GLASS: Yeah, we talked
about blending earlier.
I think that's another that you
mentioned a great way to just
explore what some of that means
and whether it makes more sense
for you to have the full
name on your visualization
or have some of the
abbreviated names as well.
ANDREW WHITBY: Three-letter
country codes are great for me.
But most people don't find
them particularly enjoying.
SHANE GLASS: Sure.
I feel the same way
about airport codes.
ANDREW WHITBY: There you go.
SHANE GLASS: OK, well,
that is it for today.
Tune in next Tuesday for
the next "Cloud OnAir."
Thank you for watching.
ANDREW WHITBY: Thanks.
[MUSIC PLAYING]